-President Trump sat down
for an interview
with Axios recently,
where he said
many ridiculous things.
Perhaps the most ridiculous,
however,
was this comment he made
while discussing the late
Congressman John Lewis.
-Nobody has done more
-Right.
-for Black Americans
than I have.
-Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin.
-Hi, Seth.
-So, Amber,
what did you think when you
heard Donald Trump say,
"No one's done more
for Black Americans
than I have"?
-I think he's correct.
-You don't disagree
with that statement?
-Why should I?
It's true.
-It is?
-It is.
-How is that possible?
I mean, what has he done?
-What has Trump done
for Black people? Well...
[ Upbeat jazz plays ]
He's done this...
♪♪
He's done that...
He's done this and this
and this...
Don't you forget about that...
♪♪
-But those are all bad things.
-He didn't say he's done
good things for Black people.
He just no one has done more,
and he's right.
No one has done more
for Black Americans.
To make our lives worse!
♪♪
He's done this...
He even did this...
♪♪
He's done this and this
and this...
Don't you forget about that...
♪♪
-Wow.
That's a lot.
-♪ And ♪
♪ Thi-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
♪ ...i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
♪ ...i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
♪ ...i-i-i-i-i-i-i-s... ♪
♪♪
-Wow.
That's...more than a lot.
So, ya done?
-Mnh-mnh.
-Okay.
♪♪
-He's done this...
He even did this...
♪♪
He's done this...
But, most of all,
he did this...
♪♪
♪ That's what he did ♪
-Thanks, Amber.